[Music]
e
for
for for
Back to the
Future
[Music]
for
for for
you
[Music]
there you can RSVP by scanning the QR
code um that will be on the screen next
is youth Sunday so twice per year we
have uh the youth the teenagers um uh at
our church run the service the Sunday
service and that is going to a week from
today will be one of those Sundays so
next Sunday we encourage you to be here
um to support them and to worship Christ
in this season of
Lent um next is an upcoming relationship
event so regardless of your relationship
status um you can join us for our
Workshop focused on enhancing
communication skills and navigating
personality
Dynamics um our hope is that through
self-discovery and practical tools you
can learn how to build a stronger
partnership this event will be Sunday
April 13th at 2 pm um and RSVP by
scanning the QR code as well and there
is free child care for those who scan
the QR code to
RSVP next is our accessibility bucket um
right over there that black bucket um if
you're anxious about being in a church
setting or you're part of the disability
community or you just feel a little
fidgety today we have some fidget tools
available um there were coloring sheets
I was supposed to bring more and I
forgot them at home I'm so sorry um but
um there normally are coloring sheets
there are noise cancelling headphones
all of those things um we just ask that
you return them at the end of
service um these candles uh that have
been lit are a sign of the presence of
Christ Among Us fully Divine and fully
human
now we exit the kingdom of noise hurry
and
productivity we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a place for prayer worship
and adoration a place to behold Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart may
we all come home
[Music]
thanks Rachel will you guys go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
with our worship set um Gary's going to
start us out on Father's house and um
I've just been reminded yesterday our
team our worship team and our Tech Team
got together for some just time to learn
some time to talk and it was such a
beautiful picture of like of church what
church is supposed to be where you have
people that like you're connecting with
like not just like roles and Ministries
and you know service orders and but
people and that's what the table is made
up of we're people and when we're here
together I hope if there's nothing else
we do we're connecting with the spirit
of God inside of each one of us and as
we come into this space every person has
a place here to connect to tune in to
the spirit of love and grace
and Beauty there's room for each one of
us here and so let's lift our voices
together tonight as we sing maybe pay
attention to the sound in the room and
remember that like we're a community
made up of individuals and all of our
stories are weaving together into this
beautiful tapestry um and that's what I
love about worship is just this combined
effort this joining in this coming
together so I hope that that blesses you
tonight as we work worship all right
Gary you want to get us
started got it
[Music]
sometimes on this journey get lost in my
mistakes looks to me like weakness is a
canas for you
strength my story isn't over my story's
just
begun you won't Define me that's what my
father
does you won't me that's what my father
does o
lay your burdens
down you're in the father's house check
his shame at the door a
[Music]
anymore you're in the father's house
rival's not the end game journe where
you are you never want it perfect you
just one in my heart and the story isn't
over if the story isn't good enough
there is never
when the father's in the room
I
never when the father's in the road wo
wo lay your birdes down wo
wo here in the father's house check your
shame at the
door welcome anymore wo
wo you're in the father's house
[Music]
y'all put your hands together with us go
come
home help
find Love Is On The Moon when the
father's in the
room come to
life love is on the moon when the
father's in the
room Miracles take
place find
love is breaking through when the
father's in the room yeah C
walls strongholds now
Shing love is breaking through when the
father's in the
room love is breaking through when the
father's in the room
wo lay your burdens down wo woah
in the father's house check your sh at
[Music]
the
wo you're in the father's
[Music]
house no shame here no fear
yeah good job kids thanks for joining in
with us hey before you kids leave can
y'all all say happy birthday Nate it's
Nate's
birthday he asked me to do that he
really begged
me all right we are going to move into
the prayers of the
people so if you guys would follow along
on our screens the parts in red we'll
all do
together Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to
you for the Good Earth you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you for the old old and
the sick for the Widow and orphan for
the injured and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experience experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names and situations up to
you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and love light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen we are leaving
crumbling
buildings full of dust
and full of
judgments we are
leaving violent
teaching from those refuse to learn from
the best of
us we are
leaving crumbling buildings
full of dust
and full of
judgments we are
leaving violent
teachings from those who refuse to learn
from the best of
us we are
leing crumbling
buildings for
d
stand full of
judgment we are
leing vient
teachings those refuse to learn from the
best of us
[Music]
we are seeking a holy healing is full of
Hope and it full of Jo jce and I've got
a feeling that we're in the middle of
it I've got a feelings you'll see us to
the end of
it we are seeking a holy healing is full
of full of
Justice I've got a feeling that we're in
the middle of
it I've got a feeling she'll see us to
the end of
it we are
seeking holy healing is full of Hope and
is full of justice and I I got a feeling
that we're in the middle of
it I've Got a
Feeling see us to the end of
[Music]
it I have deci we are seeking a holy
healing it full of Hope and is full of
justice and I I've got to feeling that
we're in the middle of
it I've got a feeling you'll see us to
the end of it
[Music]
I have
deci to follow
Jesus I have
decided to follow
Jesus no turning back
no turning
[Music]
back and the World Behind Me and the
cross before
me the World Behind me the cross before
me
the World Behind me the cross before me
no turning
back no turning
[Music]
back though none go with me still I will
follow though none go with me still I
will
follow no turning
back no turning
back no
turning back no turning
back no turning
back no tur him
back no tur him back
no turning
back no turning
back no
turning no
turning I have
decided to follow Jesus sing it out I
have decid
to follow
Jesus I have
decided to follow
Jesus no turning
back no
turning and Jesus we do want to follow
after you and your ways and your
heart God would you be our Center our
starting point our home that we return
to
God would your ways be our Compass would
they guide us towards truth and towards
light and towards
healing God would we be peace
ERS would we be people who pursued
Justice would you teach us how to be
your hands and
feet we love
you and we need
you thank you for always being
accessible to us always being with us on
this journey
you are a good God and we can trust
you we can plant ourselves we can root
ourselves into
you God help us to keep doing that as
people as a
community as a
church may we root our lives and our
mission our values into you you and how
you
loved how you laid your life
down in Jesus
name
amen thank you guys for worshiping with
us if y'all want to greet the people
around you say hello and then Brett
we'll start the message
sorry I wasn't on uh Grace and peace
welcome to the table really glad to uh
to be with you all and uh as always that
includes those join us online um don't
forget your communion elements for later
in the service and um yeah anyone here
today who is new for it's your first
time or just your first time in a long
time I'm really really glad that you're
here so um let's see we are uh well
today's the first Sunday of lint I think
if you got my email or various things
like that you're you're in the loop on
that and uh with those unfamiliar lint
is this kind of time of uh spiritual
just heart and mind preparation for uh
Good Friday um as we approach Good
Friday is the day of the Cross and then
you know on to Easter Sunday and uh well
for us Easter Saturday all of our
festivities and um so this is uh well
really the whole message will be kind of
unpacking kind of more on of like the
heart of Lent and things like that so I
won't go into too much detail now um
instead we'll get right into the message
today so the title is the grace of lint
and uh the during lint I tend to follow
the the lectionary the the kind of
prescribed readings um that the church
um I follow the Methodist Church in
their readings so um this is kind of an
interesting one it's the book of
Deuteronomy chap 26: 1- 11 I think I do
a lot of I don't know if I've done a lot
of messages on the book of Deuteronomy
but uh you get get one today um so uh it
it reads like this when you have entered
the land the Lord your God is giving you
as an inheritance and have taken
possession of it and settled in it take
some of the first fruits of all that you
produce from the soil of the land the
Lord your God has given you and put them
in a basket then go to the place the
Lord your God will choose as a dwelling
for his name and say to the priest in
office at the time I declare today to
the Lord your God that I have come to
the land the Lord swore to our ancestors
to give us the priest shall take the
basket from your hands and set it down
uh in front of the altar of the Lord
your
God then you shall declare before the
Lord your God my father was a Wandering
air man and he went down into Egypt with
a few people and lived there and became
a great nation powerful and numerous but
the Egyptians they mistreated us and
made us suffer subjecting us to harsh
labor then we cried out to the Lord the
god of our ancestors and the Lord heard
our voice and saw our misery toil and
oppression so the Lord brought us out of
Egypt with a mighty hand and an
outstretched arm with great Terror and
with signs and wonders he brought us to
this place and gave us this land a land
flowing with milk and honey and now I
bring the first fruits of the soil that
you Lord have given
me place the basket before the Lord your
God and bow down before him then you and
the Levites and the foreigners residing
among you shall rejoice in all the good
things the Lord your God has given to
you and your
household so this uh something that's
important to keep in mind really
throughout this whole message and in
order to kind of understand that passage
um is that the kind of the way when we
as Christians kind of read uh the Hebrew
Bible and in passages like this in
Deuteronomy um we're not just reading a
story about a people a long long time
ago and they kind of you know
interesting cultural customs and
religious things you know um but really
the the way we kind of map it is um that
this is something like we're on that
same Journey spiritually speaking right
so um in other words God God brings all
of us out of Egypt God brings all of us
into a good land into a land here the
languages flowing with milk and honey in
other words a place of abundance and
such so so uh kind of keep that in mind
as we go throughout I think it'll maybe
help bridge a little bit of what can
feel like a gap in terms of you know
like what does this have to do with our
lives now um so kind of think of it in
that kind of metaphorical uh kind of way
so um there's what I want to do is kind
of give you three characteristics of
lint kind of through the the lens of
Deuteronomy 26 so we'll just get right
into it so the first is this lint is a
season of me in
community so this passage is kind of
interesting in that the uh the pronouns
kind of through out it shift and change
so there in the the kind of opening
section the first few verses you have
all of this like first person uh kind of
singular pronouns you know lots of eyes
and mes and such and then you have these
uh
's now in English anytime we have the
word you like basically second person
singular and second person plural is the
same just you in other words if I say
hey you you know you're like you know is
it like you is it like Caleb or is it
you together the community you know so
it's kind of weird anytime you're
reading the Bible in English it can be a
little bit of guesswork like I don't
know is this like are they talking like
to the individual right now or are they
talking like the community um so in
Hebrew though it's not like English it
is clear in the Hebrew um this is it's
second person singular here in the
beginning it it's talking to an
individual ual so for example when it
says here in verses 1- two when you have
entered the land the Lord your God's
giving you as an inheritance have taken
possession of it settled in it take some
of the first fruits of all that you
produce from the the soil of the land
the Lord your God's giving you and put
them in a basket right it's not saying
you as a people uh no it's this is like
you the individual um but then a shift
occurs there towards as we get kind of
to the middle verse five uh it reads
like this then you shall declare before
the Lord your God now they're going into
there story right which again is is also
our story my and you could tell it's
kind of a quote here like this is what
they're supposed to go to the priest and
literally recite you know my father was
a Wandering Aran he went down into Egypt
with a few people and lived there and
became a great nation powerful and
numerous but the Egyptians mistreated
who
us made us suffer subjecting us to harsh
labor um for the sake of time I won't
keep like going through the whole
Passage but you're kind of getting the
theme here where it starts off kind of
very individual you know I me my you the
individual and then it shifts and now
it's all about us us my the Lord brought
us out of Egypt um brought us into a
good land and then it shifts again right
at the very end back to the first person
singular and now verse 10 now I bring
the first fruits of the soil that you
Lord have given me okay so you say like
why this strange English lesson um so I
I'm naming this because I think there's
such a tussle in kind of um in the
broader culture but even in the church
over this this question of like the
individual in the
community like which one is it which one
should we be emphasizing which one is
the priority which one's um better you
know is it like is it better when a
church emphasizes the
individual or is it better when we kind
of emphasize the community you can even
see this like there's um like big
questions in like worship music and such
of like should the songs we're singing
should it be like I me you know like
draw me close to you you know or like a
kind of individual or should it be we
language our us we bring us to a good
land you know that's kind of uh back and
forth with this and I think um the
answer to this question of course is yes
um in the sense that just like you see
in Deuteronomy 26 right it's not like
choosing which one it's going to address
it's to it's it's addressing both one
way we might kind of think of it is like
on the one hand there's um no such thing
as a solo
Saint right in other words um we enter
really the Christian life together I
think this is a big challenge um really
honestly for American Christians who can
be very by kind of default partly
because it's American culture very well
it's me and
Jesus and um I don't really need like
church I don't really need you know
broader Christian Community or anything
like that um me and God we're good you
know you might have heard someone say
that or even said it yourself and that's
a I would say a kind of
um emphasizing a certain perspective
perhaps too much right where it's it's
sort of like well um well because the
reality is right um our Destinies like
we are all deeply intertwined and I
think it was uh this isn't my notes but
it might have been some dead German
philosopher it might have been Hegel I
don't know but he said something like um
I am Who We
Are I Am who we are and that's true of
every human being I don't even just mean
who we are as like a church but I mean
just think of you and your life right
there's just in the same way there's no
solo Saints there's no like solo human
being
just raised utterly
isolated and alone from day one and just
becoming their own person like a blank
slate just like no it does not exist
right we're I am who we are uh we are
inescapably deeply and profoundly
communal people and you know we just
can't get away uh from that really at
all so okay so that's on the one hand
now on the other hand I'd say that's all
kind of intention with the truth that
yes there's the communal emphasis but at
the same time that can't come at the
utter just neglect of the individual
right um in other words kind of applying
it to lent like lint actually is also
about uh kind of me and Christ right
like what is my response to God just
like all those 's second person singular
you know it's not it's not just you
together lent is all of us kind of like
pursuing the Lord and you know um and I
kind of trust everyone they'll kind of
pursue God like on my behalf you know um
like no it's not really not quite how it
works we do as an individual have to
kind of take some ownership and some
responsibility and kind of step up and
say like um you know like everyone's not
going to do it for
me I've got to step up here um in other
words right this isn't about me or we
doing this for you instead you must make
your own decision for the god we've come
to know in Jesus right you must make
your own decision to um whatever lent
looks like for you whe whether it's uh
emphasizing prayer or um giving
something up or you know but that's that
is something you have to kind of own and
no one can you know do that for you um
um and I think in fact we really um we
need to do that because as the uh the
writer Maggie Ross um says she says a
community thinking of a church Community
is only as strong as the solitaries who
make it
up I think that's an interesting turn of
phrase in the sense of um the table will
really only ever be as strong as we
consist of right the other side of the
coin of individuals who say I'm going
deep with God in Christ I'm pursuing the
path of great love and then you can see
right that then feeds into the community
right I mean we would be a a a just
imagine like five years from now if each
of us as individuals kind of made that
decision who would we be and how would
we kind of bleed into one another and
influence and like who knows what God
could do right that's that's kind of
that that tension of um of these two so
you know the the season of lint um is
it's not just about me and it's not just
about the community it really is it's a
blending it's it's me in the context of
community all right so that's the the
first characteristic second one this
will go a little bit more quickly is
that lint is a season of
Grace which I'm I'm naming this because
I think we often don't think of lint as
you know oh the gracious season you know
um but I I think it actually is so
you'll notice in that that passage we
read there's a tremendous emphasis on
the action of God right it's it's all
that the middle section about the Lord
did this and the Lord did that and the
Lord called us out of Egypt and the Lord
brought us in the good land and the Lord
did this and the Lord the Lord you know
it's it's very the emphasis there is
very much on God and uh of course I
think it's the same for us right God
brings all of us out of
Egypt um whatever that Egypt has been or
is continues to be for you and God
brings all of us into a good land I'm
just looking at folks and I just know
your stories and it's such a privilege
to be in community and to see how God is
in fact bringing you into a good land uh
and to observe that in one another's
lives like it's a it's a miracle it's
it's a a beautiful beautiful work that
God's doing and um this passage right in
Deuteronomy um again this isn't it's
just not a it's not a story about people
who lived a long long time ago it is
this is us this is our story and it's
essential that we understand that our
response to God is always you might say
like preceded by surrounded by saturated
by the presence and goodness and grace
of God it's it's God's initiation in and
through us in other words anything we do
in the Linton season uh it's a response
to that Grace in love right we are not
the initiators God is the initiator and
then we're responding to uh God's love
and I think this is important because as
I kind of hinted at earlier lent we tend
to not think of lint in that way right
and lint can very much be misunderstood
as okay been living like hell all year
or you know something whatever we kind
of trash ourselves with and it's time
for me to clean up it's time for me to
get back on track and I'm gonna feel
plenty guilty plenty guilty to really
make up for everything and uh make sure
I get you know I'll really clean myself
up in order to be worthy of God's love
or something I no that is uh that's not
the spirit the spirit of lint and why is
it not the spirit of lint because that's
not the heart of God and that's not
Deuteronomy 26 and it's not the
spiritual life this not how it happens
um we might kind of sum it up by saying
everything we do is a loving response to
the grace of God in Christ not an
anxious earning of God's attention favor
or
love right that's the key so in essence
it's interesting because it might
outwardly look very similar you got two
people both you know maybe one's um ing
something giving up caffeine or
something and the other person doing the
same thing but the heart posture for
each of them could be completely
different right one could be very
fear-driven I got to get back on track
or else God's gonna get me or you know
something and the other person is in
that in that posture of Grace right and
oh thank you God you have been so good
you brought me out of Egypt you're
bringing me into a good land and from
that place from that um kind of heart
now ah here's my my loving response to
to you okay so that's the uh the second
uh characteristic lint the third is this
lint is a season of
sacrifice a season of sacrifice now you
say ah yes see this is what I'm talking
about this is what ly's all about um yes
but but let me uh kind of unpack what I
mean it's not the sacrifice of our
self-confidence um it's it's not the
sacrifice of counting and obsessing over
our sins it's not the offering of our
guilt and our shame to to the Lord is
that that makes him so happy um no no
instead lent is a season where we engage
the sacrifice of praise of worship of
Prayer of
gratitude and is there a place
for um you know confession of sin and
such sure sure absolutely um but that's
not the primary focus instead lent Roots
us in a very openhearted and even a what
I would call a joyfill kind of posture
towards God coming back to Deuteronomy
you see that again in um verse n he
brought us to this place he gave us this
land or in our case you know this this
life this beautiful life we've been
given um this land flowing with milk and
honey right abundance and now I bring
the first fruits of the soil that you
Lord have given me right so you can see
the sacrifice there there's a kind of an
offering or a gift of something but the
heart isn't you know oh I better earn
your forgiveness I better earn your love
I better get back on your good side you
like no no no that's not the heart
instead of right it's coming from this
place kind of characteristic too this
gracious place and uh and then I'm
bringing this offering place the basket
before the Lord your God um bow down
before him then you and the Levites and
the foreigners resided among you shall
what does it say read
Rejoice that's the season of lint
rejoice in all the good things the Lord
your God has given to you and your
household so you see the the entire
Linton season it's really it's a it's
like a a Well Spring of the gracious
goodness of God which means then that
our response is one of kind of
gratitude and even a certain um
ease and I I think it's important to
name that because there is a way of
engaging the spiritual life not just ly
but really all of life that is um I
learned a new word recently I'd heard
it's one of those words like I'd heard
the word I just never really knew what
it meant
neurotic um which is like perfect for me
I didn't realize it was like a neurotic
person but it's the idea of like um of
extreme or like kind of an overuse of
force like sort of approaching Life In
This Very I know what the answer is the
answer is try harder the answer is force
it more ex exert extreme will and
that'll be the Breakthrough you need and
there can be this way of engaging
Christian practice in a very like weird
neurotic way and lint can very easily
lend itself to that right where you kind
of like okay I'm GNA double down here um
I will be awesome I will be perfect I
will exceed all of God's
expectations um that's a willpower right
that's rooted in a kind of anxiety and
fear and the need to control outcomes uh
so instead what we need is this heart
posture that says you where's the grace
where's the grace in my life and then
from that we can ask ourselves not just
in lint really all through the year you
can ask yourself this question what
simple way is Christ inviting me to
align with his grace right now like
that's a beautiful way to live honestly
you can just go through every day and
just ask yourself that question like
what simple way like where's the where's
the grace right now where's the the good
thing where's the thing God's inviting
me to what's what's God already up to
and how can I just all have to do is
just like say yes to
that um I for those of you who get my e
letter you know I've I've done
occasional updates on my um my seven
months we'll just call it a process with
my my
car
uh oh man it's been bad I uh so I had
this friend it was like Dearing July I
really want to get this knocked out I
knew my transmission went out my old car
I KN knew I need a new one last July on
my July break I was like this is the
perfect time like I got to I need to get
a car you know so I had his friend work
at this dealership in Garland and uh
he's like hey I know I got you I got you
man it's going to be
great um I just didn't realize the whole
situation like it was just kind of
sketchy
and uh they were basically an out ofate
dealer who should not have been selling
any sort of vehicle in Texas and so I go
to the DMV to be like well they're like
uh or to get the title whatever and
they're like uh where'd you get this car
I was like in
Garland last famous last words it's like
they're like not in California and I was
like No And now looking back maybe I
should yes of course California no but I
just told the truth you know I'm just
like and no I got it right down the road
and they're like hm okay okay well so
this kicks off like this whole thing
where I'm like basically end up
investigating them for fraud and um
because of that though I can't I can't
get the title and it's been like it's
been a crazy process where I'm just
going from one DMV to the next like
local Garland one over to Carolton where
they can do like all sorts of like
special titles and then over to the
Dallas County tax office and then like
back to Carolton and then back to the
tax office and for those who know me uh
or have been tracking some of my journey
in this um this is my idea of hell
I some of you are like more laidback you
could this would have been super
annoying for you but you would have you
know dealt with it
I This Is My Kryptonite like
bureaucratic kind of quick think on your
feet kind of questions like do you have
form 72 Z3 why don't you have form 72
well you need that or else you can't you
know I'm just like like like I would go
to these DMV places and they have the
ticketing system you know and I would
sit there and I would have my little
ticket and I would just I look at my
hand and my hand's just shaking with
anxiety I'm like oh man so this is like
for months this is going on and it's
just the worst and finally I'm headed to
Carolton again and I'm driving there and
I'm just like you know what God I am
done I am done I have walked this out
like in the most
anxious
crazy nonc contemplative talking about
not practicing what I preach and that is
me like I'm just it has been awful and
I'm like I am I am
done and it's just I don't even know
what this means exactly but I'm just
giving it to you like figure it out like
I'll show up I'll do my part but clearly
this has been going on for that point
like six months and I I don't know what
else to do it will be what it will be
and something in me like in that moment
like shifted so I show up to the DMV and
I wish I could say and the Lord just
paved away and it just just like that I
got the title that day nope it got worse
they're like they're like um did you
know there's I don't know how we didn't
catch this before I was yeah I've been
here like five times like there is a
hidden leane on this
vehicle and I was like and my jaw just
starts like trying like basically for
those who don't know like Leen is like
where someone else owes money on the
vehicle it's like yeah so someone else
has a claim on that and my jaw is just
like and then I remember my prayer
and I'm
like deep breath I said huh interesting
well tell me what I need to do and they
gave me the instructions and I walk out
to my car and I just start laughing I
just started laughing at the absurdity
of I laugh but honestly it like wasn't a
pessimistic cynical laugh you know it
was like I was laughing a laugh of faith
I was like you know what well God it's
in your hand I told you I told you this
is your deal so we'll see how this
shakes out you know and uh sure enough
it was like honestly it was quite
incredible um so the next few weeks like
could just would drive here and there
and do the next step and then and uh
before I knew it like just things you
know it worked out in fact it was kind
of crazy time literally three days ago I
got the title and yes and
amen and you know the thing was that was
interesting is like the situation was
the situation regardless of me I could
get all worked up I could be you know
what I mean or jump up and down or or be
full of Faith or be but what I realized
was in essence like God was there before
and behind me in every moment right God
was doing his best to bring me through
that Egypt you know but the thing was I
just didn't recognize it I couldn't see
it and because of that I was just
freaking out and going about it like all
crazy and wrong and I think um it's sort
of a picture of life it's a picture of
even how we can approach lint
in other words um right the the heart of
lint it's not forcefully fixing yourself
in every situation and white knuckling
it and solving life you know no no no no
no it's it's uh
intentionally
relaxing relaxing into the grace of God
into a life of praise and worship prayer
and gratitude learning to trust that
Christ will bring us through Christ will
bring us through reentering ourselves
there so in closing what do I want you
to do well um I got you know there's
options um you can either this season
you can fast something in other words
give something up um could be social
media or sweets or alcohol or caffeine
or watching TV or complaining or
whatever honestly I did like complaining
for one one year that was like the
hardest thing I've ever passed it oh my
gosh um I put a little star uh next to
food and if you got my my email this
week you know why I do want to name to
be be careful with that one I just think
our things with our culture and body
image and food our relationship to food
and it is all screwed up it's it's
messed up and I think um and I have
known people who got themselves in the
hospital through starting fasting and it
got crazy out of P so if um if that's
something you've struggle with you feel
like your relationship to food and such
I would be really very careful um
fasting food um you might opt for for
something something else um also of
course you can not just about letting
things go but you can also engage a
thing right you can do a thing whether
it's scripture reading or prayer
meditation or journaling or uh donating
giving money or time to the poor
marginalized attending church services
and things like you know whatever
whatever God's kind of inviting you to
do it's kind of nice at times to pair
these where it's not just a letting go
of something but using some of that
extra time or energy or whatever to you
know to do uh a thing as well um but
again the whole point is to engage these
things from a a heart posture of love
and grace trusting that God will bring
you into a good land in your life so so
I pray that this this Lenton season is
one of Grace and ease for you in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so as we uh as we come to the table
of the Lord
today as we take in the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine may may it be a moment where we
start to practice that that heart
posture you know even coming here to the
table in a way that's like just open to
God just trusting in uh his love his
grace that it will meet us there um not
not forcefully trying to fix you know
ourselves and the world and everyone
around us um so the way we'll take
communion tonight um just our usual way
we'll go you know row by row here at the
front we'll just form a line um right
here and as one row finishes the next
can jump in uh we practice an open table
and if you're here tonight you'd like to
participate then you are welcome to do
that regardless of your exact you know
theology or views on XYZ topic whatever
um if you want to meet with the Risen
Christ then you're you're welcome to do
that uh you should know the red is wine
the white is grap juice and uh and then
finally you can just partake Whenever
However you'd like some folks like to
come and kneel here at the front others
partake immediately some return to their
seats but no one will lead you through
you know the exact like moment of of
partaking you can do that as you're as
you're LED so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come come you who have much
faith and you who have little you who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long you have tried to
follow and you who have failed come
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here come to the
table
for e
for
you for
if you guys would stand up with us again
as we close out tonight
we're going to sing a song called
gratitude and um let's just be mindful
of of the grace that we've been given
and approach um this week this lint
season with
gratefulness because he is gracious to
us and um and he is sharing his love
with us as we move forward and sacrifice
and um let's sing This
Together my
[Music]
words I've got nothing
new how could I
express oh my
gratitude I could sing these
songs as I often
do but every s
must and you never
do so I throw on my hands and praise you
again and
again cuz all that I have is a
heartu h
hu and I know it's
notse
foring except for a heart singing
[Music]
hu
Hallelujah I've got one response
I've got just one
move with my arms stretched
wi I will worship
[Music]
you so I thr up my hands praise you
again and
again all that I have is a Halu
[Music]
[Applause]
Hallelujah and I know it's not much I'm
nothing elseit for a
king except for a heart
[Music]
singu Hallelujah
come on my soul don't sh up your song
you got
[Music]
lion get up and PR the
Lord sing that together come on my soul
don't you get shy on me lift up your
soul cuz you've got a light and inside
of those lungs get up and praise the
Lord come on my soul don't you get shy
on me lift up your soul cuz you've got a
lion inside of those lunges get up and
praise the
Lord come on my soul don't you get shy
on me lift up your soul cuz you got a
lion inside of those LS get up and
praise the Lord
[Music]
oh
praise the
[Music]
Lord I throw up my hands and praise you
again and
again all I have is a
[Music]
halelu
Hallelujah know
it's have nothing else Fit For A
King except for a heart sing Hu
[Music]
hallelu thank you so much for being here
with us this evening um if you're new we
would love for you to fill out a QR code
uh or a card on the table on your way
out just so we can say thanks for being
here or answering any questions you have
um for meetups we could all use more
relational support and spiritual
connection the way we do that at the
table is through our meetups um if
you're not yet part of a Meetup please
scan that QR code and find one that
works for
you generosity is a key aspect of a life
of adoration and worship if the table is
your church home then we invite you to
scan the QR code to give financially or
visit the TBL tx.org
okay I'm going to to send you into your
week with a blessing you can hold your
hands out in a posture to receive or
just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go into your week
ahead with it's yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come into contact with be
blessed and we'll see you next Sunday
come on
my don't
sh
up you got a lion inside of
those up and praise the
Lord come on my soul don't you give sh
me lift up your soul you got a lion
of those L get up and praise the
Lord come on my soul don't you get sh me
lift up your soul CU you got a lion
inside of
those get up and praise the
[Music]
Lord I come on my soul don't you
shine on me lift up your soul you got a
lion of
those get up and praise the Lord
ho